so for today's talking Sharla we're
going to be taking a break from our
series that we started on living Islam
and learning our Akita and the reason
why we're going to be taking a break is
because there's a very important season
that's about to enter upon us as Muslims
possibly this time tomorrow could be the
first night of the new age' so the first
10 days of the ledger is something of
great importance to us as Muslims and
today insha'Allah we're gonna be looking
at they're looking at some of its
virtues some of its importance and at
the same time some of the recommending
acts that we can do whilst we are here
not performing Hajj as many of us that's
going to be the case so before we start
in reality it's something that we should
all be grateful for and mean particular
I'm grateful to Allah that he has guided
us to this knowledge because you find
when it comes to the Haeju and its
importance
many people are heedless of this and
it's unfortunate because these are the
best ten days in the sight of Allah out
of the whole year so this is a very
important season that we are about to
enter at the same time you find
culturally these days are slept on
unless you are actually making Hajj if
you're making hodges then of course are
important but if you're not making heard
you stay here at home then you find that
these days are just normal days and the
most that some people will do is
sacrifice but there's no real knowledge
and or real spiritual connection to
these days and their importance so
the first thing we need to look at is
what had actually is and we find that
it's from Allah as many blessings upon
us that he has made Hajj as part of our
lives on an annual basis and we find
that Hajj is this amazing Institute that
Allah has placed in our lives and at and
it has many goals and objectives that it
wishes to fulfill from the most
important goals is that it's an
opportunity for us to strengthen our
relationship with Allah it's an
opportunity for us to cleanse our souls
and become better people and you find
that the way that Allah does this is
that he introduces many different acts
of worship into our lives in these first
10 days and at the same time he revives
many different acts of worship that we
already know and that we are already
practicing throughout the year but he
puts emphasis and these first 10 days
and he places and he makes it that if we
do these deeds he gives us many many
robots he makes it a blessing time a
time of barakah from these lessons that
we learn and from the ebody that we
perform in the first 10 days of the
religion particularly at the time of
Hajj is learning the correct belief
about Allah we leave everything to
worship him and him alone and sacrifice
everything that we can and every aspect
of Hajj we learn about the oneness of
Allah whether that's through the
prophets and messengers that passed
before us like Ibrahim alayhi Salaam and
his son Ismail and we follow many of the
rituals that they place there for us
what we learn about actually by that in
particular like the talbiya for an
example the Bakke Elohim Allah big every
aspect of Hajj teaches us about the
oneness of Allah and now if you want
happiness in this life and the next is
our responsibility to fulfil his worship
from the lessons that we learn from Hajj
is cleansing our soul and its importance
from them is responding to the call of
Allah but you find soup on Allah many
people are heedless of the fact of
making hydrogen making Amara and other
people wish that they could go so panel
Allah has not decreed that for them and
it's not their time just today's soup on
Allah there was a hospital visit that I
attended and there was an older uncle
from the community that was ill two of
his sons had to cancel their Hajj last
minute because their father may Allah
cure him and make the affairs easy has
fallen really ill so you find that no
matter wha
we sometimes may intend and we may think
this is the time that say I'm going for
Hajj I'm going to do this deed Allah has
a greater plan and sometimes it's not
our time to go and fulfill these ebuy
that sometimes it may be that we are not
spiritually ready and it takes time from
the lessons that we learned from Hajj is
making the vicar of allah remembering
allah frequently from those lessons is
having a Tabaco complete and perfect
reliance upon allah will you find when
somebody embarks upon that journey he is
literally in the hands of allah where he
is in a new land a new language new
weather conditions new everything
gathered with millions and millions of
people he leaves his family behind
everything is in the hands of allah and
that's one of the lessons that we
learned from hajj from those lessons is
making a Toba turning to allah in with
sincere repentance and we spoke about
this last week and from the lessons that
we learned from Hajj is remembering our
final abort remembering the next life
and remembering death
and this is done in many different ways
from that is the haram the white clots
that we wear to be equal with everybody
else reminds us of the shroud that
people are buried in that we're going to
be buried in at the same time gathering
on the plains of Arafah
it reminds us of the gatherings of yawm
al qiyamah where everybody's going to be
extracted from the graves and be
questioned so that's from the lessons of
Hajj from the lessons of Hajj is
understanding the importance of unity
everybody is united as one OMA dressed
the same in the era nobody can
distinguish one from the other and it
shows us how Islam has come to remove
all social ills like racism and
tribalism and all these are the
different diseases that the communities
have from the lessons that we learned
from Hajj is disgracing the Shaitaan by
obeying Allah and not falling into the
temptations that the Shaitaan puts there
for us and from the lessons is giving a
sugar being thankful to Allah being
grateful and from the lessons of Hajj is
sacrifice but we don't the sacrifice and
slaughter the animal but we sacrifice
our desires and our whims and that which
we wish for that which Allah has decreed
for us it's also important for us to
understand that from Allah as attributes
is that he creates whatsoever He wills
and he chooses whatsoever he wills he
creates whatsoever He wills and he
chooses whatsoever he wills before we
enter understand what this means
we look at where this comes from it
comes from the ayah in the Quran where
Allah says Arabic is lucuma Isha away
after that your Lord he creates
whatsoever he wills and he chooses
whatsoever he wills so we learn from
Allah attributes is that he chooses
whatever he wills what does this mean
who can explain what this means to me
what do you think
Sagan don't know Kosar silligan the
question again
for those that weren't paying attention
like Coulter is a book is lucu my assha
away after the law creates whatsoever he
wills and he chooses whatsoever he wills
what does this mean who can give me some
examples of what allah has chosen he
chooses when you go he chooses certain
people and when they go for hajj xyn
arts culture a lot uses many many
different things for the money generally
yeah okay so we find that a lot uses
many different things he chooses certain
people like the prophets and messengers
from the whole of mankind and he chooses
them to be the best of mankind and those
and he leaves the example for us to
follow and try to emulate to the best of
our ability at the same time he chooses
them the the people who speak on his
behalf and relay the divine messages to
us right he chooses people in the sense
that he has chosen us to be alive and he
has chosen for us to have this ability
to gain this reward and chooses certain
places before that we find subhanAllah
there are many people that were
preparing to go for Hajj or preparing to
do a bad that here our home for the
first 10 days of the ledger and a lot of
decree that they are not going to see
the ledger they're going to pass away
before them
so just the fact that we are alive and
he has given us this opportunity to
benefit from these days then this is
something which we have to be grateful
for and make the most often at the same
time Allah has chosen certain places
like like Mecca for an example he is
placed much it'll Haram his house there
and the sacred must [ __ ] and whoever
prays once Allah there is that praying
how many a hundred thousand anywhere
else a hundred thousand anywhere else he
has chosen other masajid and made them
the best places made him the best places
on this planet and he has given him that
great virtue of being called his house
where its purpose is to establish his
worship in many different ways to serve
the local community where he's actually
worship the people gathered together to
worship Him with salah and Juma and
other than that so Allah chose is
whatsoever He wills and he places gives
that thing worship virtue another
example of this is sometimes a lot uses
times and he makes them virtuous like
the time of Juma the best time the best
day of the entire week other times you
find a lot uses months like the month of
Ramadan and he has made that the best
month over the 12 other months we find
that a lot receives nights like he has
chosen the night of al Qatar and made
that the greatest night of the entire
year at like this Allah has chosen the
first 10 days of the Rieger he has
chosen the first 10 days of dhul-hijjah
which we may be entering upon this time
tomorrow could be the first of the first
night of the 10 days and he has made
these days the best days as we're going
to come to learn of the entire year
one of the reasons why this is who can
tell me the time of Hajj what else it's
one of the four sacred months cousin
yeah that's when the Hajj is performed
[Laughter]
the question is why is it that la has
chosen these ten days to be the most
virtuous over the rest of the days but
why what's the wisdom behind them one of
the reasons that scholars given that's
correct as well wrong the reason that
scholars give is that it's the only time
of year that the five pillars of Islam
are being acted upon at the same time
the only time of year so we find the
towhead of Allah that's going to be
acted upon in every aspect of our lives
maybe worship Allah and only Allah and
then we find when it comes to salado's
being implemented throughout the year at
the same time you find when it comes to
zakah people are going to be paying
their charity money sometimes to feed
the the kobani that they make if it's
applicable well they're going to be
given this occur anyway because the
nisab is come around that time of year
or some people will delay until this
time to get the extra reward so we've
got three the photon is fasting you find
that one of the most virtuous things
that you can do is fast in these verse
nine days in particularly the day of
Arafah
and then of course Hajj it's the season
of Hajj so one of the reasons why this
is so special and so such a great time
is because it's the only time of year
that the five pillars of Islam are going
to be acted upon and implemented across
the world at one time
simultaneously with regards to some of
the virtues of this month before we get
there when we say that this is a blessed
time or it has virtue what do we mean by
that we mean basically for them yeah
you're supposed to do stuff in these
times and Allah from his mercy and from
his kindness and from his compassion he
places a great amount of reward there
yeah we're gonna take that but we find
the Allah chooses these times that we
mentioned Ramadan ladies of God that the
first ten nights of the Haeju the first
ten days of the ledger
it's from Allah's mercy in his
compassion but he chooses these days and
gives them virtue so that we can act and
do righteous deeds and seek His
forgiveness and the many different deeds
that we're going to mention so we can do
these and get a greater reward than
doing it outside of this time the reward
is multiplied and that is from a large
mercy and from his kindness so we find
when it comes to the virtues of these
first ten days the first virtue that I
bring to your attention is that with the
prophet sallallahu alayhi wa sallam said
after lo I am in dunya Elisha the best
days of the entire year are the first
ten days of the Haeju the first ten days
of the religion and the reason why is
like I mentioned it's the only time of
year that the five pillars of Islam are
acted upon at one time at the same time
it's important that this is it's
important that we understand that this
is a big claim saying that something is
virtual saying that something is the
best time of the year in the sight of
Allah just ascribing something to the
Deen of Allah saying Islam says this
Allah said this the process and said
this this is in reality something which
is a big claim because you now are
speaking on behalf of Allah
and it's important that we only ascribe
to Islam that which is from Islam so we
can't just turn around and start saying
things as we please and for you new
Muslims or the younger brothers that are
new to practicing the Deen it's
important that you understand that
whenever somebody ascribes something to
Islam we have to ask is this in the
Quran is this in the sunnah of the
prophet salallahu alayhi wasalam if
we're saying we're gonna get closer to
allah by doing a certain deed then we
have to be able to establish that from
our religion and if we don't do this we
are in we are choosing or we are we are
choosing for Islam to be forgotten and
it's true and purest form because if
everybody starts adding to Islam as they
please an attribute into Islam as they
please then the reality is the true
message the process I'm left behind as a
gift of guidance for the whole of
mankind is going to be forgotten so when
we say something is from Islam and of
course sometimes the intentions are
caught well we need to make sure that
that's something which is actually from
Islam it's actually from the Quran it's
from the son of the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam so the first virtue is
that these are the best ten days of the
entire year the second virtue is that in
these 10 days the good and righteous
deed is more beloved to align these 10
days and the rest of the year
meaning the reward is multiplied as the
prophet sallallahu sallam said ma'am in
a Yemen amylose Allah will fear a hobble
in Allah him in javi in a young that
there are no days there are no days in
the entire year that the righteous deed
is more beloved to Allah than these 10
days so again we again we understand the
importance of Allah's mercy and how
generous he is in reality
that he has made these days and he
didn't have to but they are more beloved
to him and we do a righteous deed in
these days a reward is multiplied the
Sahaba asked of Solomon the same hadith
not even the one that makes jihad
processer not even that person that
makes jihad except for the one that
loses everything in the battlefield
meaning his life and his wealth he's the
one that can come close to this reward
showing us the great opportunity that we
have in front of us that this
opportunity is not something which is
small and it's not something that we can
afford to be heedless of his next 10
days are serious days where we have to
struggle and strive to worship Allah as
much as we can from the virtues of these
10 days is that Allah mentions them in
the Quran and as we know what a lonely
mentioned that which is important in
some places Allah will tell us in the
Quran of their importance and that at
the time of Hajj and he'll encourages to
increase in his worship in particular
his remembrance in one place Allah
mentions the hadoo manaphy Elohim with
course mullah if he am in Muhammad
al-amin Resaca who mean by mean by him
Attilan am so that they may witness that
which is of benefit to them talking
about the people and they go for Hajj
and that they may increase in the
remembrance of Allah in the well-known
days the well-known days here according
to the scholars of a tough see from the
Sahaba like abdullah bin abbas and other
than him have all said this is referring
to the first ten days of the ledger so
the fact that allah not only mentions
them in the quran but he tells us about
their virtue and he tells us that this
is a time for us to increase in his
worship is something that should
motivate us all other times in the quran
we find in allah speaks about these 10
days he takes an oath by them where he
says well fudge it when i add in a sh
where he takes an oath by the time our
forger and by these 10 days now we know
that Allah is only ever going to take an
oath for us to try to comprehend that
this is something serious that which is
going to talk about something of great
importance and at the same time he's
only going to take an oath by something
which is serious and important and as we
know we can only swear by Allah Allah
can swear by whatsoever he wills he
takes an oath by many different things
in the Quran but us as Muslims we only
take an oath by Allah so we find Allah
makes reference to these ayah to these
10 days in different places in the Quran
from the virtues of these days is that
the ninth day is the day of Wow
the day of Arafah and this has many
virtues in and of itself it's the most
important day of Hajj it's the day of
forgiveness where the person told us
it's the day that Allah comes down to
the lowest heavens the closest that we
that we are to him and he asks the angel
why have all these people gathered in
this state wearing the same clothes the
shovels tired
why have they gathered and the angel and
of course he knows but he's giving them
virtue by mentioning them and the angels
will say they have come here to seek
your forgiveness and Allah will say
because of this state that they're in i
forgive every single one of them showing
us that the day of Arafah is the most
important day of Hajj and is the day of
his forgiveness and also we find it's
the day that the Torah is accepted as
the Prophet SAW sallam told us the best
two are that one can make is the day
that the door of the day of Arafah
and the best to add me and the other
prophets and messengers made was la
ilaha illallah wahdahu la sharika lahu
more coalition hadith this is the best
application talking about the towhead
and the oneness of allah and how
everything
belongs to him and how he is over all
things capable and how all praise
belongs to him and him alone so it's
also the day of the are also the problem
told us about this one day of Arafah the
the person that fasts on that day who's
not making Hajj this inshaallah has the
reward of having the sins of the
previous year and the sins of the coming
year to be forgiven so this is something
we should all strive to do to fast on
the day of Arafah for those that are not
making much also we find that this is
the day and the day of Arafah was the
day that Allah perfected uncompleted his
religion and we learned this from that
which Imam Bukhari and Muslim mentioned
that a jewish man came to Omaha may
Allah be pleased with him and said to
him o amirul mumineen you as muslims
have a verse that was sent to you in
your book if we as the jewish community
had this verse revealed to us we would
have taken this day as a day of eid as
the day of celebration whom were asked
which verse is this and he told him it
was the verses where allah says a glioma
a camel telecom Dinoco but mum to
alaykum at meteora d to laka ma islam
Idina that today i have completed your
religion for you and i have completed my
favor upon you and i am happy for you to
take islam as your way of life omaha may
allah be pleased to me said i know where
this verse was revealed and the
circumstances of it being revealed he
said it was on a friday on the day of
Arafah when the process of salaam made
his hajj these verses were revealed to
him so this was the day that la
completed his religion
how many hydrogen the process Allah make
in his life he made one hatch what year
was the Hajj revealed
well yet it had to become part of Islam
finally er anything else anything
different the Hajj became part of Islam
became legislated in the ninth year the
process Allah made Hajj in the tenth
year but the year before that it was
legislated but the problem did not make
Hajj because he was busy dealing with
the different delegations from across
the Arabian Peninsula he was giving them
dower they would come to visit him and
learn about Islam the different tribes
and he was teaching them about the
religion of Islam but he did send a
delegation of Sahaba that was led by Abu
Bakr Siddiq
and as many different Sahaba in that
delegation and it was announced at the
Hajj that this is the last time that the
mushrikeen of Mecca are going to be able
to make Hajj and the year after that the
process of Salam came and he made Hajj
and on the day of Arafah these verses
that I mentioned to you in surah maidah
the third verse was revealed to the
Prophet SAW Salim and after these verses
are revealed to him he only lived for a
very short time who can tell me how long
the person lived after these verses were
revealed three months anything else
it was 80 days plus some passed away 80
days after this and we're going to be
looking at the process of salams passing
away further on in the course each other
when we learn about Salah
the point here is this was that one of
the virtues of the day of Arafah
something that we need to ponder over is
that a large house this time to complete
and perfect his religion force from the
virtues of the ledger is that we are
supposed to ponder as a line curry Jesus
in the Quran we are supposed to ponder
over alas favours upon us and we
understand this from where he says faith
grows mala if he am in Muhammad al-amin
Ruzicka whom mean by him attila nam an
increase in your remembrance of allah in
the well-known days speaking about the
first 10 days of the ledger for that
which he has provided for you including
that which is given you from cattle that
you're going to slaughter and sacrifice
so in these days we're supposed to
ponder and reflect over last favors upon
us and at the same time they're supposed
to give that so that that sacrifice and
of course from the virtues of the ledger
is the actual sacrifice that we make
which is us following the Sunnah of the
Prophet Ibrahim alayhi Salaam as we know
from his story he was somebody that was
tested with not having children until he
became really old and he was tested
throughout his entire life you look at
the story of Abraham alayhi Salaam and
perhaps in the future we can speak about
this some of the lessons that we learned
from his life so upon Allah you find he
was tested throughout his entire life
and Allah gave him opportunity after
opportunity after opportunity to get
closer to
up until he became the Halil of allah
the intimate friend of allah because he
sacrificed and went through every test
and trial and he saw that as an
opportunity to get closer to allah so we
learned that when he was blessed with
his son Ismail Allah ordered him to
sacrifice that son to make another
sacrifice and straightaway as we learn
in surah suffered he sacrifices him and
a lot of places that with the with the
RAM or the sheep and from day that's
where we take this ebody
of sacrificing and the person came and
he sacrificed himself and he made it
path our Hajj as well so from the
recommended acts of worship that we
perform is sacrificing in these first 10
days with regards to some other other
deeds that we can do then like I
mentioned these are all opportunities
for us to increase in our reward and get
closer to Allah and cleanse our souls so
we should be increasing in all of the
deeds that we did that we should be
doing anyway so increasing reading the
Quran making dua increasing in our Salah
and giving in charity all the different
ebody that was supposed to be doing
we're supposed to be doing more
increasing in those ebody from those
deeds that we should be aiming to do is
fasting on the day of Arafah as the
possum told us it's a means to have our
sins forgiven for the year that has
passed and the year that's going to come
at the same time we find reports from
the prophets wives may Allah be pleased
with them all that the process of Salah
would fast the first nine days when he
was not on Hajj he would fast the first
nine days so fast in the first nine days
is also something which is recommended
and of great benefit in particularly the
Monday and Thursday fasts of course like
we mentioned sacrificing is something
which if we have the ability
we should try to do and if we are going
to sacrifice then don't cut your nails
or your hair up until the anima animal
has been sacrificed unless there's a
need or a necessity for you to remove
that hey all that male or if you forget
there's no problem with that also
there's no problem that also and the
sacrifice has to be done after they eat
Salah has to be done after the Eid Salah
you can't do it before so if you're
going to send it abroad or get so the
charity is here to do it for you get
that point clarified that's going to be
done after they eat Salah and not before
from the bad that the law encourages us
to do at these times is making a vicar
is remembering Allah and of course is
that vicar which is general awesome told
us when these first ten days come
increase in your dust be your Subhan
Allah alhamdulillah Allah Akbar la ilaha
illa llah
this is something which was supposed to
increase in and then there's that which
is specific which is the takbir at from
the from the day of Arafah up until the
day of eid where we are going to be we
make the TEC Murat Allah Akbar Allah
Akbar la ilaha illallah allahu akbar
allah wa lillahil hamd we increase in
that as well
after the Salah wat from the acts of
worship that we should be doing in these
10 days is making though our like we
mentioned the possum told us that these
10 days are the best days that we can
make duaa in and the problem told us
that he best to add me and the prophets
that came before me made was la ilaha in
the LA ilaha illa allah wa l-hamdu ala
kulli shayin Qadir and also we find in
ending i mentioned this point that we
have to remember we are now in the
summer holidays and we are responsible
as we are throughout the year we are
responsible over our children and they
nurturing nurturing them and they are
bringing in the turban that we give them
so these 10 days we should be increasing
in acts of worship as a family and
increasing the ebody that we do as a
family and bringing life to Islam in our
houses in an easy and in a soft way and
making it encouraging encouraging them
to do good deeds and making it fun and
interactive and at the same time eid is
going to be fast approaching it's
important that we make the most of Eid
and bring life to these celebrations and
use these opportunities to instill the
correct belief and the correct a man
into our children because you find
unfortunately our children sometimes are
more content and are more happy with
Christmas and Easter to celebrate and
one of the reasons of that is because we
have we have been neglectful and been
heedless in making sure these events are
special for our children and there they
are being fulfilled spiritually and that
they can enjoy themselves this is what I
wanted to present here today and surely
Allah knows best you guys have any
questions until the athan you can you
can ask now inshallah what can be done
and quarter past twenty past okay we've
got time see there again know as
talking about surah fatah when frigate
while al inertia is talking about the
first 10 days of the religious of the
lobby numbers and other Sahaba mentioned
and Allah knows best
crow Feist whoever has the ability to
sacrifice then he should do so it's not
a wide jib it's not obligation whoever
has the ability should do so and if
somebody does it on behalf of his
household then that's something which is
good also I mean what I mean by Abel is
you have the financial means to do so
again know the person himself will know
if he is financially capable of
sacrificing I mean in this country we're
not going to take the take the ship to
houses and slowly ourselves what I mean
by Abel is financially able that he has
the ability to spend give it to all
these charities if we're gonna do it
here or do it abroad you can sacrifice
on behalf of your late father and Shama
with regards to which one's better
sacrificing here or sacrificing in
another country the processor of himself
would sacrifice in his own region and he
saw Salaam won't keep some of the meat
for himself distribute some to the close
neighbors and then he would also give to
the poor the reality is the homeless
people that we have here in the city
I think perhaps given them a bag of me
is not the most best thing to do in the
sense that if they're homeless they're
not gonna have anywhere to cook that
meat at the same time when it comes to
neighbors and things because it's a time
of Eid everybody's freezers are gonna be
full anyway right so um sometimes the
meat is gonna go off it's just gonna be
wasted so it may be better to give it to
somewhere abroad where there's a need
for it or if you're gonna do it here in
the UK then give it to like a like a
food bank for an example that cooks that
me and has like a soup kitchen that they
can give it out the most ideal thing is
given it to a soup kitchen that can cook
that me and they can serve out on to the
people that are in need that's the most
ideal thing if that's not an option then
personally and of course all knowledge
and wisdom is with Allah I personally
think give it to another country with a
ring where they're in dire need of it
and Allah knows best
Aziz Nam Kubelik
Adam Fiat I am also a bell-curve ear
Lyanna a Yammer photo with aura from
insha Allah and to Adam had he at am but
I am Bali and they saw he had in the
loop pull in win the lon
okay we stop here for them the regards
to fasting then from my from my
knowledge ease that there's the reports
on base in the prophets life indicate
two things the majority of the prophets
wives they said the process on fasted
meaning all nine days I shall may Allah
be pleased with her said no that's not
the case so if somebody wants to fast
nine days a one-goal they can so what he
wants to the Monday and Thursday now
Rafa they can do that also
so then the issues white inshallah they
the next week
last week sorry
I don't remember Sangha yeah I don't
think we discover with regards to the
prophets and messengers then they are
masoom they are faultless and sinless
with regards to when it comes to
conveying the rosanna here they don't
make any mistakes with regards to that
reality it's not counted because as we
as we took last week it was something
that Allah completely forgave her the
Malayalam for right so it's it doesn't
go against Adam in any way but rather
Adam making that mistake was something
that we learned great lessons for and
hopefully we took some of them last
weekend Sean